next question hey David will coronavirus
finally be the catalyst we need for
people to do mass call outs of work
large-scale strikes coordinated mortgage
and rent defaults and all of those other
protests and activism techniques that
you've been talking about beautiful
question I have talked about those
techniques before I've said many many
times signing petitions online okay
calling your elected officials great but
that in order to really change the
system from the point of view of an
activist you may have to be willing to
participate in some other types of
protest and this includes as the
question asks large scale strikes mask
all-out strategic defaults etcetera the
question of whether coronavirus will
cause that to happen really comes down
to one element and that's how long does
this all last and the reason I say that
is that for a lot of people the $1200
stimulus is not going to be enough
people on unemployment will be able to
sort of remain afloat treading water
assuming that this doesn't last that
much longer than what the models suggest
and most people and this is a feature of
the system not a bug from the purposes
of corporate the corporate hock recei as
soon as things start to open back up
people are going to have to go back to
work okay this is how the system is
designed so I often say to you one of
the impediments to mass rallies to
change the system is that the system
makes it so that people have to keep
going to work people would potentially
lose health insurance if they bail on
their job the system is insulated from
being changed by how it sort of controls
the people that are working within the
system so in the same way right now a
lot of people are staying home
and people understand particularly on
the left that you've got to stay home to
stop the spread of the virus so right
now you're not going to see those mass
rallies because people are doing the
right thing once things start to open up
the people who have been staying home
are also likely to understand the
importance of getting back to work to
feed their families and to get caught up
with rent or mortgages or whatever the
case may be so the system has a way of
perpetuating itself by always making it
difficult and inconvenient and very
risky to actually go out and do that
type of protesting now as far as you
know formal rent strikes for example a
coordinated rent strike would be large
swaths of people say we are not paying
rent on this day or we are not paying
our mortgages on this day a strategic
mortgage default there's no doubt that
if it comes down to you pay your rent or
you buy food or you buy medication I
would expect that rent comes after food
and medication of course every situation
is different depends what is the
medication I get it but generally
speaking that is probably the case but
remember evictions have been slowed down
or stopped in many areas there are
places that have done rent and mortgage
deferrals now importantly that's not
forgiveness a lot of people I hope are
understanding but I fear that some
people are not when you talk about a
rent deferral for three months that
means you don't pay April 1 May 1 June 1
rent but on July 1 you owe all four
months now maybe it'll be phased in
maybe you've got to make up half of each
of the deferred months per month through
the end of the year or something like
that still a lot of it is up in the air
but those deferrals are only deferrals
it is not forgiveness and that is going
to be a problem on the tail end for a
lot of people if you needed to defer 1
months of rent are we likely to imagine
that you're going to be able to afford 4
months of rent on July 1st it doesn't
strike me that way but again when it
comes to the system I don't know that
you will see as many rent in strategic
mortgage defaults
because evictions and foreclosures have
been slowed down or stopped in many
parts of
country and again it's the system
perpetuating itself the system
protecting itself this gets me back to
the beginning ultimately this will
depend on how long this goes it's early
but there are starting to be some
improving numbers in many US states and
in many countries around the world
social distancing must remain but it is
not crazy to think that at some point in
the not-too-distant future I allow the
doctors to tell us when I'm not even
going to speculate some elements of the
economy may be ready to be opened back
up including with young workers people
who test positive for antibodies meaning
they've already built an immunity to the
coronavirus etc and that one factor how
long this goes and how successfully we
stop the spread is going to be primarily
the determining factor as to how
motivated people are to look at
large-scale strikes maskala etc my
prediction is anybody who can get back
to work whenever it is mostly people are
going to be glad to do that and given
the choice between starting to ant earn
money immediately or going and striking
most people I'm not saying this is good
or bad I'm just saying this is most
people are going to choose to get back
to work and to start earning money
that's my prediction let me know if you
disagree let me know what you think
should happen with regard to mass
rallies and call outs we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today get
instant access by becoming a member at
join pakman.com